auf mallorca gilt jetzt eine masken
pflicht gesundheitsminister sparen warnt
vor einer zweiten welle wenn die
urlauber wieder zu hause sind
europa sucht einen umgang mit china
obwohl der druck aus peking auf die
menschen in hongkong zunimmt verzichtet
die eu auf scharfe massnahmen und
manchester city klagt sich in den
europapokal
die uefa hatte den verein wegen
verstößen gegen das finanzielle fairplay
ausgeschlossen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem montag an meiner seite ist für
den sport norbert lehmann junior familie
wir müssen aufpassen dass der ballermann
nicht ein zweites ischgl wird so der
appell von gesundheitsminister sparend
heute zwar stünde deutschland bei der
korona bekämpfung im moment relativ gut
da aber weltweit seien die
infektionszahlen so hoch wie nie deshalb
gelte es gerade auch in der urlaubszeit
wachsam zu sein
aus berlin florian 9 sie feiern als wäre
das virus längst besiegt mallorca am
freitagabend hunderte deutsche urlauber
ohne maske ohne abstand was in berlin
den bundesgesundheitsminister an einem
der ersten hotspots der pandemie
erinnert in österreich müssen sehr
aufpassen dass der ballermann nicht ein
zweites spiel wird in die gefahr einer
zweiten welle ist real
wir sollten daher wachsam bleiben wir
sollten nicht übermütig werden das gelte
zum beispiel für urlaubsreisen etwa mit
dem flugzeug
wobei der chef des robert koch-instituts
den flug selbst für weniger gefährlich
hält als die zeit davor für die
linienflugzeuge ist den luftaustausch
und die filterung sehr sehr wichtig sehr
effizienten eine größere problematik ist
der zugang zu flughäfen und das auf
reihen der passagiere wenn es zum
einchecken geht wichtigste maßnahme auch
hier abstand hygiene alltags masken und
generell möglichst viele tests in der
vergangenen woche wurden in deutschland
eine halbe million menschen auf das
corona virus getestet ein neuer rekord
möglich wären sogar 1,1 millionen tests
dass die kapazität nicht vollständig
genutzt wird erklärt der minister so wir
haben halt insgesamt auch natürlich ein
infektionsgeschehen auf niedrigem niveau
in dem moment wo zahlen sich irgendwo
verändern werde natürlich auch viel mehr
tests wieder gemacht von einer möglichen
durchseuchung ist das land derweil noch
weit entfernt so das zwischenergebnis
einer studie des rk ii 12.000
blutspenden wurden untersucht nur bei
1,3 prozent fand man antikörper für das
corona virus also einen hinweis darauf
dass die betreffende person bereits
infiziert war
die behörden von mallorca hatten schon
vor dem party wochenende geschlossen ab
heute gilt auf der insel eine strenge
masken pflicht auch im freien
wer über sechs ist muss mund und nase
bedecken sonst drohen 100 euro strafe
thomas walde es hat sich herumgesprochen
und dem ersten augenschein nach wirkt
die bußgeld drohung von 100 euro auf der
playa de palma
auch wenn die haupt reisegruppe nicht
begeistert ist von mahle mit maske
leider müssen wir durch verschiedene
touristen die hier wirklich vor ort wohl
über die stränge geschlagen haben müssen
wir leider darunter leiden
es ist natürlich relativ schwierig es
macht ja keinen spaß hier am strand
entlang zu gehen oder bummeln zu gehen
mit der maske gerade bei über 30 grad
ich krieg da noch schlecht luft ich
jetzt 50 zentimeter weiter links laufen
würde bedeutet ich muss keine maske
tragen
ich stehe jetzt aber hier und muss eine
maske tragen dass diese masken pflicht
ist in der theorie sicherlich wichtig
und auch gut in der praxis habe ich ein
großes fragezeichen strand am pool beim
sport beim essen soll die masten pflicht
nicht gelten
hoteliers fürchten gleichwohl dass die
neuen regeln reisende abschrecken
könnten
und es ist schon gravierend es werden
wieder noch nicht was uns also auch sehr
weh tun
die verantwortlichen bleiben trotz
solcher befürchtungen bei ihrer
entscheidung
wir hoffen dass die touristen die
sicherheit positiv sehen werden die wir
auf den balearen anbieten
sie brauchen erholungssuchende damit die
wirtschaft nicht weiter einbricht aber
zu viel lockerheit könnte
infektionszahlen steigen lassen
ein zielkonflikt auch aber nicht nur auf
mallorca hier in deutschland bleibt die
zahl der neuinfektionen auf niedrigem
niveau im durchschnitt der vergangenen
woche haben sich täglich 340 menschen
neu angesteckt gestern waren es 360
auch in italien ist mittlerweile die
zahl der neuinfizierten vergleichsweise
niedrig die wirtschaftlichen folgen der
pandemie allerdings sind immens nach
schätzungen der eu-kommission bricht das
bruttoinlandsprodukt in diesem jahr um
11,2 prozent ein
zum vergleich die prognose für
deutschland liegt bei minus 6,3 hinzu
kommt ein schuldenberg der wohl auf fast
160 prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts
anwachsen wird
italien hofft nun auf das geplante
hilfspaket der eu vor dem gipfel ende
der woche ist ministerpräsident konnte
deshalb auf werbetour heute bei der
bundeskanzlerin klaus brodbeck sich
näher kommen in zeiten von corona der
gemessene abstand bleibt die gefühlte
distanz aber zwischen berlin und rom ist
deutlich geringer geworden auch dank der
deutschen bereitschaft für den
wiederaufbau europas schulden zuzulassen
der blick in den schlosspark von
meseberg strahlen der in europas zukunft
her nicht möchten wir auch dass wir in
großer freundschaft und verbundenheit
jetzt die beratungen in brüssel
durchführen die uns allen eine chance
geben sollen aus diesen
großen humanitären desaster aber eben
auch auf sehr großen wirtschaftlichen
schwäche die daraus erwächst möglichst
gut heraus zu kommen konnte wird in
meseberg für italiens reformkurs
energiewende ein green new deal der
abbau von italiens berüchtigter
bürokratie und ein besser
funktionierendes justizsystem
wir müssen schnell handeln schnell
reagieren die geschichte lehrt uns die
beste reaktion ist nicht viel wert wenn
sie zu langsam kommt investitionen in
die zukunft stattzufinden hat und dass
da für diese investition eines so
besonderen einzigartigen und noch nie
dagewesenen weges eines solchen fonds
der über garten auch die kommission gibt
und dann einer späteren rückzahlung
abgewickelt wird beide lassen offen ob
schon der krisengipfel in brüssel am
wochenende entscheidende
weichenstellungen bringen kann weitere
treffen also nicht ausgeschlossen
wir bleiben bei der eu in brüssel stehen
heikle themen auf der tagesordnung der
außenminister die sich heute seit langem
mal wieder persönlich trafen zum einen
geht es um das schwierige verhältnis zur
türkei
zum anderen um das vielleicht noch
schwierigere verhältnis zu china
das umstrittene sicherheitsgesetz für
hongkong ermöglicht chinesischen
behörden dort hart durchzugreifen
aus brüssel berichtet anne gellinek
wiedersehen mit maske zum ersten mal
seit fünf monaten kommen die
europäischen außenminister leibhaftig in
brüssel zusammen auf der suche nach
einer gemeinsamen position im verhältnis
zu schwierigen partner
die türkei ist offiziell noch
eu-beitrittskandidat auch wenn die
verhandlungen de facto eingefroren sind
das land entfernt sich immer weiter von
europa als illegal eingestufte probe
bohrungen nach gas im mittelmeer
waffenlieferungen nach libyen trotz
embargo zuletzt die umwandlung der hagia
sophia in eine moschee
rookies cup breite unterstützung dafür
die türkische regierung aufzurufen diese
maßnahme dringend zu überprüfen und
zurückzunehmen
österreich fordert den abbruch der
beitrittsgespräche mit der türkei bleibt
damit aber allein in der eu und dann ist
da noch das angespannte verhältnis zu
china
die europäer haben das sogenannte
sicherheitsgesetz für hongkong
kritisiert zu sanktionen entschließen
können sie sich nicht stattdessen werde
man menschenrechtler aus hongkong nicht
mehr ausliefern keine gummigeschosse an
die hongkonger polizei verkaufen
stipendienprogramme ausweiten
es kann nicht so sein dass alles so
bleibt wie es ist wenn das
sicherheitsgesetz in hongkong angewandt
wird dann wird das ganz konkrete
auswirkungen haben müssen
für fragen der rüstungsexporte konkrete
auswirkungen auf das verhältnis zu china
keine europa will die sprache der macht
erlernen gleichzeitig aber fürchtet sich
die eu vor einem handelskrieg mit china
in zeiten der rezession und auch mit der
türkei kann man sich wegen der
flüchtlingspolitik keinen streit leisten
es bleibt also dabei europas weltpolitik
fähigkeit ist gleich null
nach polen und zur stichwahl ums
präsidentenamt das war ein
kopf-an-kopf-rennen zwischen zwei
kandidaten deren positionen
unterschiedlicher nicht hätten sein
können
aber jetzt ist klar gewonnen hat
amtsinhaber du da mit 51,1 prozent der
stimmen sein kurs nationalkonservativ
der herausforderer der liberalere und
proeuropäische laskowski kommt auf 48,9
prozent
das ergebnis zeigt wie gespalten das
land ist aus warschau zum paulus ein bad
in der menge und das in corona zeiten
präsident angie du da ist auf sieger
tour im dorf otto 100 kilometer von
warschau entfernt haben ihn die
allermeisten gewählt hier schlägt er
versöhnliche töne an
nach seinem wahlkampf mit homophoben
parolen und auch verbalen attacken in
richtung deutschland
wie ich gestern sagte wenn jemand
beleidigt war von dem was ich gesagt
oder wie ich mich verhalten habe
entweder während des wahlkampfs oder in
den letzten fünf jahren bitte ich das
eben vergibt allerdings sagte er gestern
auch dass er nichts was er im wahlkampf
behauptet habe bedauere die glückwünsche
des unterlegenen reformers kowski kamen
per twitter danke für jede stimme
schreibt er für den liberalen warschauer
bürgermeister ist das ergebnis trotzdem
ein erfolg so eine aufholjagd hatten vor
wenigen monaten viele nicht erwartet wir
haben bereits gewonnen unabhängig vom
ergebnis weil wir es geschafft haben
aufzuwecken und hoffnung zu schaffen das
knappe ergebnis zeigt jedoch den riss
durch die polnische gesellschaft land
gegen stadt ost gegen west arm gegen
reich brücken bauen wird eine von dudas
größten baustellen wenn er das rückgrat
dazu hat die chance ein bisschen ein
anderes polen auch zu leben und
versuchen die getrennten lage wirklich
die quer durch die familien gehen
zusammen zu bringen und zusammen zu
bringen und noch eine gelegenheit könnte
präsident da nutzen
seinen kritikern beweisen dass er mehr
ist als ein erfüllungsgehilfe der
regierung
natalie steger in warschau was bedeutet
du das sieg für die zukunft polens und
auch für presse- und meinungsfreiheit im
land
das bedeutet erst einmal dass der weg
weiter der weg von jaroslaw kaczynski
ist der mächtige peace parteichef du da
ist sein ziehkind du da könnte sich
jetzt eigentlich emanzipieren es ist
seine zweite und damit ohnehin letzte
amtszeit aber danach sieht es nicht aus
duda hat gesagt er will die justizreform
diesen umbau der justiz weiter
vorantreiben er würde als entsprechende
gesetze unterschreiben was bedeutet für
die medien nun öffentlich rechtlicher
sind bereits fest in peace hand das
haben osze-wahlbeobachter heute auch
moniert in einer pressekonferenz sie
haben gesagt im wahlkampf sei tvp
wahlkampf vehikel für den amtsinhaber
also für du da gewesen und es liegt auch
bereits ein neues mediengesetz in der
schublade von der kies da geht es um die
sogenannte re politisierung da will man
den anteil ausländischer verlage an in
polen erscheinenden medien reduzieren
also auch da will man mehr einfluss
nehmen und der präsident ist auf
regierungslinie die einschätzung unserer
polen korrespondent in natalie steger
vielen dank im hafen der kalifornischen
stadt san diego brennt seit gestern ein
us kriegsschiff das feuer war offenbar
nach einer explosion ausgebrochen
mindestens 21 menschen wurden verletzt
die meisten seeleute konnten das schiff
unverletzt verlassen
als der brand ausbrach befand sich nach
angaben der us marine keine munition an
bord die feuerwehr rechnet damit dass
die löscharbeiten mehrere tage dauern
könnten
die ursache für die explosion ist unklar
schwere aufgabe für die polizei im
schwarzwald sie fahndet nach einem
bewaffneten mann von dem niemand sagen
kann wie gefährlicher ist
sicherheitshalber wurden schulen und
kitas in oppenau geschlossen
spezialeinheiten hubschrauber und eine
hundestaffel sind im einsatz
der 31 jährige hatte gestern vier
polizisten bedroht und ihnen die waffen
abgenommen als sie ihn kontrollieren
wollten
dann war der mann ohne festen wohnsitz
in den wald geflüchtet
nochmal zurück zum thema corona in
sachsen sollen die schüler nach den
sommerferien wieder ganz normal
unterricht haben in der schule also
regelbetrieb mit hygieneregeln
rückendeckung dafür gibt eine studie der
uniklinik dresden das ergebnis schulen
in sachsen haben sich bisher nicht als
hotspots von neuinfektionen erwiesen
die einzelheiten von stefan kech eine
große pause die schon sehr nach
normalbetrieb aussieht doch ist das hier
nur die hälfte der schüler des dresdner
gymnasiums klatsche die andere hälfte
lernt weiterhin zu hause wie seit wochen
so darf es nicht weitergehen meint der
schulleiter der schüler setzt vom lehrer
dass die sozialkompetenzen werden
gestärkt er ist mit seinen schülern
zusammen und lernt entlassen kann seine
fragen stellen bekommt sofort antworten
und alles was digital abläuft kann nur
ganz aussicht auf normalisierung gibt
eine studie zu corona erkrankungen in
schulen 2000 sächsische schüler und
lehrer wurden auf antikörper untersucht
nur zwölf hatten welche auch in den
schulen in denen in den chor oder videos
infektionen nachgewiesen worden waren
haben wir keine ausbreitung festgestellt
das heißt also es ist auch eine ganz
kleine zahl von schülern und lehrern
begrenzt geblieben es hat keine aus
breitungen in einzelnen schulen gegeben
die verteilung der infektionsraten über
diese schulen den dreck über den
landkreis und die stadt dresden weg sind
konstant unter einem prozent gewesen
der studie nach seinen schulen also
keine hot spots für kidd 19 kinder
scheinen bei der übertragung des virus
keine zentrale rolle zu spielen
nach den ferien also bildung im
normalmodus
regelbetrieb heißt dass es in den
klassen stattfindet und dass der
reguläre stundenplan die entsprechende
fächer verteilung gilt regelbetrieb
bedeutet aber auch dass es ein
regelbetrieb unterbinden pandemie
bedingungen ist das natürlich weiterhin
schutzmaßnahmen notwendig sind denn
diese rückkehr zur normalität an
sachsens schulen wird es nur geben wenn
die infektionszahlen so niedrig bleiben
wie heute in sachsen also kein messbarer
anstieg der infektionen durch schul
öffnungen die ergebnisse und
hintergründe der korona studie aus
dresden haben wir auch online für sie
zusammengefasst in unserer zdf heute
weniger babys in deutschland die zahl
der geburten ist im vergangenen jahr
leicht gesunken rund 700 78.000 kinder
wurden geboren
das sind 9400 weniger als 2018 das
teilte das statistische bundesamt mit
dass es gegen den trend der vergangenen
zehn jahre mit steigenden geburtenzahlen
gestorben sind letztes jahr mehr
menschen als kinder geboren wurden
dieser trend hält bereits seit 1972 an
und jetzt zu dir norbert und einem
urteil des heute für furore sorgt in
sachen manchester city allerdings die
uefa die hatte ja den englischen fußball
club wegen verstößen gegen die financial
fairplay regeln bestraft zwei
spielzeiten sperre für den europacup
city zog vor den internationalen
sportgerichtshof und gewann eine
folgenschwere schlappe für die uefa
große triumphe sind sie gewohnt bei
mancity vier meistertitel seit 2012 doch
dieser sieg könnte der größte sein
dokumente aus den football leagues
enthüllungen liegt nahe zahlungen des
club besitzers aus abu dhabi sollen als
sponsorengelder getarnt so die uefa
finanzregeln umgangen worden sein
die fairen wettbewerb garantieren die
vorwürfe seien nicht bewiesen oder
verjährt urteilt der internationale
sportgerichtshof cas bestätigt aber eine
strafzahlung wegen mangelnder
kooperation des vereins bei den
ermittlungen allerdings reduziert von 30
auf 10 millionen bis youtube blick für
die uefa hat das gravierende
auswirkungen vor allem was das financial
fairplay die finanzregeln angeht eine
schwere niederlage
auch englands fußball-ikone gary lineker
kommentiert trocken finanzielles
fairplay am ende auch die uefa selbst
der verband hält sich bedeckt die gefahr
dass trainer pep guardiola starensemble
ohne champions league-teilnahme
auseinanderfällt ist gebannt große siege
in europa weiter möglich alles ganz fair
findet zumindest der kasse zum
tennisturnier in berlin seit der korona
pandemie ist das die erste profi
sportveranstaltung in deutschland mit
publikum das wichtigste für die
tennis-asse nach der langen zwangspause
zwangspause
das sammeln von spielpraxis die erhoffte
spielpraxis sie bleibt begrenzt julia
görges muss verletzt aufgeben
deutschlands nummmer 2 jan lennard
struff unterliegt dem spanier akut im
tie-break stattdessen setzt der 42 jahre
alte tommy haas ein dickes
ausrufezeichen in einem duell der
generationen gegen yannick szene aus
südtirol noch keine 19
und als eines der größten talente im
tennis gehandelt haas bei seinem mini
comeback beileibe nicht so als wäre er
drei jahre lang weg gewesen
im gegenteil ein äußerst umkämpftes
duell mit vielen finessen
es hätte mehr zuschauer verdient gab
längst nicht erreicht wurden die 800
erlaubten senna gewinnt knapp kommt ins
halbfinale aber haas imponiert da darf
sein rentnerdasein am wochenende auf
hartplatz noch einmal unterbrechen
wer nicht die zuschauer ein
ja das war ein gemäßigter anderen gut
zum wetter dieser sommer gefällt sich im
hin und her morgen wird es sowohl sonnig
als auch regnerisch die details hat
gleich bad honnefer bettina schausten
freut sich auf sie im heute journal um
viertel vor zehn
danke für ihr interesse haben sie noch
einen unbeschwerten abend und bis morgen
wenn sie merken
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren heute gab es
strahlenden sonnenschein und die
temperaturen kletterten auf 19 bis 28
grad
jetzt in der nacht wird es wieder frisch
vor allen dingen dem vogtland oder auch
in der donau und im allgäu sinken die
werte bis acht grad milder bleibt die
nacht am rhein oder auch hier auf
norderney mit 14 kraft meist ist der
himmel nämlich klar aber an der nordsee
kommen schon die ersten regenwolken
heran und die breiten sich bereits
morgen vormittag weiter in richtung
emsland aus noch einmal strahlenden
sonnenschein gibt es morgen hier
zwischen dem spreewald und im allgäu
erst am nachmittag versüßt dann auch
dort einige wolken den himmel
der regen zieht etwas weiter nach
südosten und erreicht am nachmittag das
saarland den harz und die ostseeküste
und es können noch einzelne gewitter
dabei sein dazu weht der wind recht
kräftig aus südwestlichen richtungen die
temperaturen sind morgen ganz
unterschiedlich im nordwesten unter den
grauen wolken sind das nicht mehr als 17
bis 20 grad sonst werden 22 bis 28 grad
erreicht
am mittwoch gibt es dann ziemlich viel
regen für uns alle
es sind auch einzelne gewitter dabei am
donnerstag lockern die wolken von
nordwesten schon wieder auf und der
freitag mit dann schon wieder ganz
freundlich schönen abend noch